go ahead put in your mouth go since the
first time it was announced to the
public that we are growing these there
are literally thousands of YouTube
videos of people eating Carolina Reapers
all over the world but I get a kick out
of most of them though it can be
unpleasant it's not a dangerous thing to
eat super hot peppers it's a chemical
reaction your brain perceives as heat so
you will stop doing it
[Music]
I'm smoking egg curry I created the
Carolina Reaper I got into breeding
peppers in college Minh just really was
interested in getting hotter and hotter
peppers once I tried them Guiness
awarded me the world record for the
hottest pepper in November of 2013 to
breed these things I crossed a ghost
pepper with a habanero and what came out
was this evil looking pepper it had
warts all over blisters they call them
and the first time I tasted it it
knocked me to my knees we get our
peppers tested regularly at Winthrop
University by dr. Calaway in the
chemistry lab all peppers are measured
by Scoville heat units which tell you
how hot the pepper is bell peppers have
zero Scoville heat units Tala Pino is
about five thousand a serrano 20,000 red
habaneros 200,000 ghost peppers 600,000
then you get to the Carolina Reaper
which is one point five six nine million
Scoville heat units the hottest thing in
the world when you eat the Carolina
Reaper the first sensation you get is
sweet and then all sudden the heat
starts going it's like burning burning
burning then the physiological stuff
starts your eyes will bloodshot they
just start tearing up and watering the
skin flushes you start breathing hard
but your metabolism starts raising up
some people say it's like eating molten
lava others will say it's like licking
the Sun to me it's like eating a
charcoal briquette and no matter what
you do you cannot get that burn out of
the back of your mouth I mean it's crazy
a lot of what I do is creative
expression you will look for traits in
one pepper and you look for traits in
another and you try to combine them and
keep both those traits there are other
breeders who are trying to break our
record but we've been holding unreleased
peppers in our back pocket that are
twice as hot or more than the Carolina
Reaper that we could submit to Guinness
it
my perception of what the limits are of
how hot you can greet a pepper has
changed as the science has progressed
over the years just tell me something
can't be done I'm gonna figure out a way
to do it
[Music]